la page d'accueil du site internet
indique simplement que le journal
suspense et publication jusqu'à la fin
de l'opération militaire russe en
ukraine pour ses parutions en ligne
comme pour celle au format papier la
décision du journal indépendant russe
novaïa gazeta intervient après un
deuxième avertissement des autorités en
moins d'une semaine officiellement pour
manquement à la loi sur les agents de
l'étranger le rédacteur en chef de
novaïa gazeta dmitri mouratov a reçu en
2021 le prix nobel de la paix pour son
engagement au sein de son journal il a
décidé la semaine dernière de faire don
de sa médaille d'une belle à un fonds
destiné à aider les blessés et les
réfugiés ukrainien lundi jour de la
suspension de son journal il a fait
savoir à ses lecteurs qu'il n'y avait
pas d'autre solution que c'était une
décision terrible et douloureuse mais
qu'il fallait se protéger les uns des
autres depuis le déclenchement de
l'opération militaire les autorités
russes ont renforcé la répression de ce
cas qualifie de fausses informations les
sites de nombreux médias russes ou
étrangers ont été bloqués novaïa gazeta
était jusque là l'un des tout derniers
bastions de la presse libre encore en
activité en russie notamment connu pour
ses enquêtes sur la corruption et les
atteintes aux droits humains en
tchétchénie novaïa gazeta faisait figure
d'exception dans le paysage médiatique
russe cet engagement a coûté la vie à
six de ses collaborateurs depuis des
années 1990 dont la célèbre journaliste
anna politkovskaïa assassinée en 2006